we've heard so much from Republicans
especially Donald Trump about so-called
voter fraud rigged elections and so on
Trump ranted about it constantly during
the election he kept complaining about
it after he won three to five million
illegal votes were cast for Hillary
Clinton a combination of undocumented
immigrants people voting multiple times
never presented evidence we now have a
little more evidence although it's not
exactly the type of evidence that Trump
wants we have now learned about a
criminal investigation into voter fraud
committed possibly by one of Donald
Trump's closest advisors propagandist
Steve Bannon it's being reported by the
Washington Post that trumps own chief
strategist Steve Bannon is under
criminal investigation for voter
registration fraud he's being
investigated for regice registering to
vote in Florida while owning a house in
Southern California and regularly living
in Washington DC and New York he is
registered to vote in an empty house in
Miami that's set to be demolished he
used to rent the house to his ex-wife he
told the landlord that he was living
there and the Invista the specific
investigation here is alleging that he
put false information on a voter
registration form saying that he lived
there so to remind you about the the
sort of background on this being
registered to vote in multiple places is
legal I've said it before I'm probably
registered in two places right now
as long as all of those places are
places you could conceivably be legally
registered in submitting false personal
information on a voter registration form
saying you live somewhere that you don't
is a felony in Florida it's punishable
by up to five years in prison the
reality is that Bannon didn't vote in
Florida and he's an older wealthy white
man so that lessens the possibility that
he would actually be prosecuted here the
state's attorney's office for miami-dade
County is not commenting on the
specifics of the situation but they did
confirm that there's a criminal
investigation active and he was later
removed from voter rolls in Florida
because databases indicated Hayes
registered in multiple places doesn't
actually appear that he lives here
what's very interesting is that on top
of the allegations from Donald Trump
which wouldn't actually be indicative of
criminality right people registered in
multiple places many of trumps
associates including actually Donald
Trump's own daughter Tiffany Trump are
registered to vote in two places and
again as long as you can make a case for
legal registration in both places
that is not in and of itself illegal
what Steve Bannon is being accused of
investigated for I guess I should say to
have clarity this evening
would actually be against the law